Ayahuasca is hard to spell.
A-y-a-h... uasca?
Maybe I should go grab some, that might be
easier.
Hey all, Trace here for DNews.
In 2015, the United States got its first legal
ayahuasca church that promised to provide
“ayahuasca spiritual healings” to members...at
a price.
It was quickly shut down a year later, with
skeptics calling the church a cult and a scam.
But… is there an actual benefit to using
ayahuasca, and what is it in the first place?
Ayahuasca is commonly used by indigenous communities
in healing ceremonies in the Amazon rainforest.
It’s a tea that produces hallucinatory effects
after consumed.
But many consider it a miracle drug, treating
a number of disorders, including depression.
But is this scientifically accurate or are
we just drinking up some ancient placebo kool-aid?
Ayahuasca is traditionally made from the leaves
of one shrub (Psychotria viridis) and the
stems of another vine (Diplopterys cabrerana).
When digested together, they introduce a fairly
famous compound called DMT into the blood,
which eventually finds its way to the brain
and causes hallucinations.
But DMT has a not so famous partner, harmine,
which in addition to hallucinations, has antidepressant
qualities.
Harmine was first found in ayahuasca in 1996
in the plasma of volunteers who drank it.
According to botanist Dennis McKenna, "Most
people seek ayahuasca with good intentions
- they are not thrill-seeking but are curious,
serious - or have specific issues such as
depression."
There have been studies to back up ayahuasca
as a treatment for depression.
Most recently, one study published in PeerJ
exposed human neural progenitors — cells
that are capable of becoming neurons — to
harmine, resulting in a 71.5% increase in
human neural cells.
This is similar to other antidepressants,
which cause, what’s called, neurogenesis.
But this isn’t the first study of its kind.
There have been several studies done on ayahuasca
usually with small a sample size...like really
small.
But because there aren’t that many in the
overall scientific literature, we thought
they were worth mentioning.
One study with 6 volunteers found improvements
with their mood after drinking ayahuasca within
hours (typical antidepressants could take
weeks).
Another study had 3 women with depression
drink ayahuasca, and their symptoms decreased
for two weeks afterward!
And in a 2015 PLoS One study, they linked
the ayahuasca’s “altered state of consciousness”
to decreased activity in parts of the brain
associated with depression.
There’s even a meta-analysis of various
studies on ayahuasca and its antidepressive
effects from the past 25 years.
They concluded that ayahuasca is a “useful
pharmacological tools for the treatment of...mood
disorders.”
It’s actually pretty difficult to conduct
studies on ayahuasca...considering DMT is
classified as a Schedule I substance by the
US Drug Enforcement Agency, banning it from
medical use.
Many of the studies we mentioned here happened
in countries where it’s allowed for religious
purposes including Brazil and Peru.
In which case, researchers would have to wait
for the perfect series of events: volunteers
who experience depression and are willing
to drink ayahuasca.
As for larger controlled studies outside of
religious exception, we may just have to wait
a bit longer.
As always, more research is needed.
What other psychedelic drugs do scientists
think might have medicinal benefits?
Find out in this video here with my girl Cristen
Conger.What other science questions do you
have about stuff like this?
Let us know down in the comments, make sure
you subscribe for more DNews and thanks for
tuning in.